how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course everything relating to the MCU
and today we have some really awesome
and pretty hilarious MCU news concerning
Deadpool making his way over to Disney
and in the Marvel Cinematic Universe now
if you've been watching my videos or if
you've been keeping up with everything
going on with Deadpool and the MCU right
now everything that Ryan Reynolds has
been saying everything that Rob Liefeld
has been saying you're gonna find this
pretty funny and if you haven't don't
worry of course I'll explain the
situation but of course the biggest
thing to take away from this is that
Deadpool is a priority at Disney Disney
and Marvel Studios are currently working
on a third Deadpool movie and that is
definitely going to happen and I'll
break it all down in this video if
you're new be sure to subscribe to stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU including Deadpool and so you can
enter my giveaway this week to win a
Captain America Funko pop from Avengers
end game all you have to do to enter is
subscribe like this video and leave a
comment down below so to catch everybody
up real fast on what's happening is that
lately there's been some confusion on
whether or not Deadpool is actually
going to be coming to the MCU and
there's actually going to be a third
Deadpool film made and there's a reason
for everything and it's very easily
explained so one of the reasons that
there's a lot of confusion is because
Deadpool creator Rob Liefeld and also
producer of the first two Deadpool films
came out publicly and said I blame
Marvel for their not being a third
Deadpool film he came out and said that
it's not a priority to them they are not
working on it but then he climbed to
have seen Kevin Feige 's Secret lineup
for the next five to ten years of movies
now as it turns out this wasn't true and
I could have told you that without
hearing anything about it Kevin Feige is
not showing that list to anyone the only
way that anybody is seeing that list is
if they cite an NDA a nondisclosure
agreement which means if you tell
anybody
Kevin Feige will sue the crap out of you
but what really happened was as it turns
out Marvel Studios and Disney aren't
going to have Rob Liefeld on the project
for Deadpool 3 he is not going to be a
producer so it seems like there's a
little bit of bitterness here and that's
why he came out saying all of these
things
to top it all off Ryan Reynolds has been
playing extremely coy about Deadpool 3
he's been talking about it a lot he's
been saying that it would be amazing if
Deadpool would be in the MCU but then he
would say things like I hope it happens
again easily explainable and I'll talk
about that in just a second but just
yesterday we basically got a
confirmation that Deadpool is being
worked on over at Disney and Marvel
Studios right now and that he is coming
to the MCU and this came from Bob Iger
the former CEO of Disney and current
executive chairman Bob Iger changed his
header on Twitter and here's the reason
why it's hilarious he has all sorts of
different Disney characters on the
header' he has a few Disney Princesses
he has Minnie and Mickey Mouse he has
Elsa and Anna
he has Bart Simpson baby Oda and then he
has some Avengers and Marvel characters
he has Captain Marvel Black Panther and
then in the very corner of the banner
you can see Deadpool holding his thumb
up that's right Bob Iger made it a point
to change his twitter header and
specifically have Deadpool in the header
this is definitely him trying to stick
it to Rob Liefeld and Rob Liefeld even
commented on the fact he posted a tweet
with a picture of Bob iger's new twitter
header and Twitter and he said I am
doing the Lord's work
now you can interpret that as you will
I'm not 100% sure what exactly he's
trying to say but I think we all pretty
much know what's happening here
Rob Liefeld was left out Deadpool 3 is
continuing on at Disney and Marvel
Studios and he's a little bit heard
about it which of course I think anybody
would be but Disney and Marvel have a
specific direction that they want to go
now there is a production grid for
Deadpool 3 that is official and it lists
the producers as Ryan Reynolds and Kevin
Feige so Deadpool 3 is definitely
happening and Bob Iger changing his
Twitter header and having Deadpool in
the header confirms it even more and
that's the reason Ryan Reynolds is all
of a sudden playing kind of coy about it
because it is happening and he can't
give away any spoilers
he's already mentioned in the past that
Deadpool is over at Marvel Studios now
and they are in fact working on Deadpool
3 he specifically said they are working
on Deadpool 3 now now recently he's only
said it would be great if Deadpool 3
half
and existed in the MCU but that's
because he can't give it away now he
specifically said I'm playing in the big
leagues now over at Marvel and since
he's playing in the big leagues he has
to play by their rules so even though
Ryan Reynolds isn't so upfront about
Deadpool 3 anymore
don't worry it is definitely happening
so let me know what you think about this
little kind of funny drama that has been
happening lately and let me know how
excited you are about Deadpool 3 and
Deadpool being over and Marvel Studios
now leave your thoughts down below don't
forget to drop a like and subscribe so
you can stay up to date on everything
relating to the MCU for live updates you
can follow me on Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof